slow-cooked fiery lamb cooking's all
about being bold and adventurous
and this dish is exciting because it's
slowly cooked and the longer it cooks
the more flavoursome it becomes
marinating the lamb first chili's we're
going to use a mixture of red
and green take off the tops and just
slice
in garlic
crushed don't worry about chopping these
ultra fine just
get it in there cooking for up to three
hours
everything sort of blends and almost
sort of purees itself together
smoked paprika goes brilliantly well
with the chillies
two teaspoons in a touch of dried
oregano
some little cumin seeds the blend and
the fragrance
that they give out is extraordinary they
release a little oil as well
and helps to tenderize the lamb a touch
of salt
pepper cinnamon
that sort of sweetens up the lamb
olive oil just a tablespoon
and the olive oil helps to sort of stick
all those wonderful spices
to the lamb jump in just start
really rubbing at this stage you can
leave the lamb to marinade for anything
from half an hour to overnight
allowing the spices to really penetrate
the meat giving amazing results
when you tuck in delicious vegetables
carrots and onions and that's it sliced
secret slicing vegetables for braising
is not getting too thin
you slice the onions too thin they burn
you've got that horrible char
taste on that slow braised grazing it's
just a chef's term that means cooking in
liquid on a low heat
making the meat incredibly moist and
beautifully tender
so the secret of braising is having a
really nice thick
durable pan get that nice and hot
just a touch of olive oil lamb in
hold the bone because you're in control
then into the pan
i want that white fat to start rendering
so it'll add more fat therefore making
it
a lot more flavoursome as it braises
chili's cinnamon
in mix that up and don't be scared
you're not burning this you're sort of
searing the lamb shanks and this is the
important part right at the very
beginning
we're getting the color on the lamb
which washes off as it braises in the
oven so
be generous with that color vegetables
in
wow and then a couple of baileys
so now you lift the lamb up and get the
lamb
sat on top of the vegetables now just
glaze the pan with red wine
deglazing means that you're you're
cleaning the bottom of the pan and
you're getting that amazing flavor
washed off and lifted up into that sauce
can really transform
that dish always delays then bring to
the boil and cook for about 10 minutes
to reduce
the wine is reduced down by half now for
the stock
bring that stock back up to the ball and
then into the oven now
don't cover it when you cover it all the
condensation comes off
the lid your lamb becomes gray all this
effort and that
exciting spice gets washed away no lid
and into the oven for three
a hours cook on a low heat of 160
degrees gives the spices time to work
and transform the meat so it's
mouthwateringly tender
now look at those
out on to a plate you can just see that
meat
sliding down juicy and then creamy
tender
grab it by the shank roll around that
rich delicious sauce
look at that and get your sauce
nice beautiful just get some mint
don't chop it just pick that fresh mint
and let it
snow and there you go a very spicy
delicious melting of the mouth lamb
shank
amazing
when you're cooking for a special
occasion you want to nail some key
things
one your recipes need to be bulletproof
you don't want a disaster
on the big day two as well as tasting
phenomenal
they have to be easy to serve so you can
relax and enjoy yourself
three when you're out to impress food
needs to look great too
my first recipe fits the bill perfectly
stuffed lamb
with spinach and pine nuts stuffed meats
are perfect for special occasions they
look
impressive taste amazing but more
importantly they are so
simple to do
pan on for the stuffing it's a saddle of
lamb
basically a sort of rolls-royce cut
perfectly shaped
and it suits stuffing to an absolute tea
for the stuffing finely chop an onion
garlic nice thin slices
oil in onions and garlic
in salt
and pepper make sure the stuffing is
beautifully seasoned so it helps to
season the inside
of the lamb now we've got the color on
those onions
we're gonna throw in some pine nuts and
that helps to
give a bit of a texture
here's where it starts getting really
exciting
spinach in and just lay the spinach over
the pine nuts
it looks like a lot of spinach that's
gonna condense and disappear
almost instantly
there's so much more flavor and spinach
when you saute it as opposed to
steaming it or boiling it gas off look
at that
now to bring that together no eggs no
breadcrumbs
crumpled feta over the spinach feta
cheese
adds a beautifully salty sharp and
creamy flavor
what this does it brings our stuffing
together
now open up the lamb
keep those little fillets to the side
that's the channel that we want to stuff
so i want to just open that up a little
bit there
salt and pepper lightly
and before we put our stuffing in we're
going to season it with
soon sumac is a wonderful lemony spice
that goes brilliantly with lamb and you
can get it in most big supermarkets
and it sort of cuts through that thick
rich sweetness of the lamb
open up that lamb there
take a spoon if you're preparing this
for the day
ahead then let the stuffing cool down
it's inevitable when you start rolling
it and tying it
something's gonna squeeze out so load up
the ends
take these beauties these little fillets
and just support
that stuffing and sort of increase
that beautiful tunnel and then from
there
over there and bring that
towards you and then roll like i said
some of the stuff is going to come out
now to tie it
first off around the side and don't
worry about some flash
butcher's not just tie it
one in the middle you can get butcher
string from your local butcher
or at cookware shops i got two ties
go too tight it just forces all that
stuffing
out of the lamb when it's in the oven
nice
now we just season the top of it
roll the joint to make sure all the skin
gets seasoned
now you think normally that just goes in
the oven like that that's how my mum
would do it but
get your tray onto the gas oil in
get it really nicely colored none of
your stuffing is coming out the sides
really important
look at that color beautiful does
kickstart
the roasting process gas off into the
oven
cook for 45 to 55 minutes depending on
how pink
you want your lamb
lift the lamb out of the fat to rest
resting it raised up in the tin will
stop it cooking
but not cool it down too quickly and
means you won't lose any of those lovely
juices
next i'm making a simple but
sophisticated accompaniment for the lamb
top and tail the cucumber peel it
cut the cucumber into three
and just core taking out all that it's
just sort of
watery seedy and it spoils the flavor
slice cucumber
cucumber in really nice way of making a
cheap and cheerful cucumber look
glamorous we're gonna dress that
cucumber with a nice fresh
yogurt couple of tablespoons next
some fresh mint dressing a touch of salt
a touch of pepper and then pomegranate
molasses that just sweetens it up
finish that with lemon
mix that up
lamb it's rested carefully take off the
string
and then just gently pull them back a
straighted-edge knife that's going to
cut through that
crispy fat on the outside instantly i
tied it purposely so i can get
my portion control from the lines hold
it nice and firmly
look at your line where the string was
and look
this one is going to be amazing lay and
down
just in those two slices there it proves
that stuffing
for special occasions because that is a
saddle of lamb at its absolute
best stuffing meats and fish
not only makes them look fantastic it
also gives them an extra added flavor
dimension too
once you've mastered the technique
you'll be able to turn out dishes that
will guarantee
you'll have an unforgettable feast
you